Emmanuel Macron pour l'instant n'a pas
donné son accord pour faire l'émission
Face à Baba donc en fait on est devant
un problème c'est à dire que il y a un
problème d'équité et on est extrêmement
regardé par l'arcom voilà qui est
nouveau CSA et on peut pas faire deux
heures avec Marine Le Pen si on fait pas
deux heures avec Emmanuel Macron
donc on pensait que la solution c'était
de pouvoir faire deux heures avec Marine
Le Pen qui a voulu venir et deux heures
peut-être avec des soutiens d'Emmanuel
Macron mais le problème c'est que là
c'était compliqué d'en faire venir aussi
parce que c'est vrai que s'il n'y a pas
c'est compliqué de faire venir ces
soutiens donc
pour le moment donc c'est ou annuler ou
reporter avec Marine Le Pen qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez vous ici est-ce que
vous pensez qu'on aurait dû essayer de
trouver des solutions le problème oui
c'est qu'on peut avoir une amende et
qu'on peut être hors la loi par rapport
à l'arcom vous l'avez vu aussi Élysée
2022 l'émission de France 2 Marine Le
Pen voulait la faire le président
sortant n'a pas voulu la faire donc ils
ont dû aussi Annuler pour des questions
je vous dis c'est vraiment timé ça veut
dire que si vous faites deux heures avec
Marine Le Pen vous devez faire deux
heures avec Emmanuel Macron c'est la
règle vous est-ce que vous pensez qu'on
a pris la bonne décision est-ce que vous
pensez qu'il fallait aller contre ses
règles et prendre une amende ou voilà
c'est qu'il fallait moi je pense que oui
non non vous avez pas pris pris la
décision déjà je pense que ça aurait été
évidemment un carton d'audience ensuite
Marlène chapelle a dit à quelques mois
que vous auriez pu animer le débat de
l'entre-deux tour c'était pas le débat
mais ça aurait été une grande soirée
événement avec un des candidats donc
vous auriez encore plus marqué la
campagne et ensuite moi et je parle de
tous les candidats j'en ai marre des
candidats qui font la loi dans les
médias pendant cette campagne il y en a
qui veulent pas être interviewés par tel
ou tel journaliste il y en a qui veulent
pas débattre il y en a qui veulent pas
faire des missions au détriment d'un
autre candidat au bout d'un moment c'est
la campagne les candidats doivent
s'exprimer c'est leur rôle c'est une
émission très sérieuse qui regardait par
énormément de gens qui ne s'intéressent
pas forcément à la politique et je pense
que les deux candidats ont fortement
intérêt à faire cette émission je trouve
ça très dommage que parce que l'un de la
fait pas l'autre ne la fasse pas non
plus alors je voudrais vous rappeler le
principe du face à ma base spéciale
qu'on voulait faire sur
l'entre-deux-tours c'était donc les deux
candidats les deux finalistes face à
citoyen DJ citoyen 10 français qui ont
jalonné le dernier quinquennat un gilet
jaune un infirmier un anti-vax enfin
quelqu'un qui contrôle vaccin qui se
pose des questions ce que j'aime pas le
terme d'antivax je préfère le terme de
quelqu'un qui se pose des questions sur
le vaccin oui non voilà un enseignant un
policier
donc on avait dit c'était les mêmes 10
on voulait faire exactement les mêmes
intervenants pour Marine Le Pen et pour
Emmanuel Macron donc c'est ça le
principe en direct bien entendu c'était
donc sur ce plateau vous vous pensez
Matthieu je sais que c'est Mathieu tu
vas me dire dans un instant Mathieu vous
pensez qu'on aurait dû la faire
évidemment alors dites-moi je pense qu'à
un moment où tant pis pour la com et je
suis désolé il y a un moment il faut
violer les lois lorsqu'il s'agit pardon
lorsqu'ils agit d'un enjeu national
aujourd'hui on est pas à 34 60 on est à
49 51 c'est un véritable enjeu 48,52
voilà c'est une émission qui va être
regardée énormément par les jeunes qui
vont voter donc c'est une émission très
importante or je rappelle que Marine Le
Pen a donné son accord Emmanuel Macron
lui a proposé il refuse c'est son
problème il refuse c'est son problème
mais c'est pas parce qu'il refuse qu'il
doit empêcher les autres eux d'aller
parler donc soit il y va soit
éventuellement il envoie ses
commissaires pour lui mais c'est bloqué
entièrement bloquer entièrement comme la
démocratie et un débat qui va être
extrêmement important au moment où je
vous parle vous n'imaginez pas dans les
dîner familiaux le nombre de personnes
qui ne savent pas pour qui on va voter
49 51 cette émission elle est cruciale
on est en train d'enlever un débat pour
la démocratie qui va être extrêmement
important parce que je vous le dis sur
France 2 pardon j'ai rien contre France
2 quand je regarde avec mes neveux qui
ont voté pour la première fois ils ont
20 ans et 18 ans France 2 avec Harley je
sais pas quoi avec Nathalie saint
criquet tout et regarde 2 minutes il
s'en foutent ça les fait chier face à
Baba et vous la regardez il voulait
comprendre donc je pense que je suis
désolé si amande il y aura et ce sera
regrettable je ne paierai pas mais ce
sera regrettable mais il faut absolument
y aller demain c'est un enjeu national
et là on parle vraiment de cinq années
donc tant pis et si vous le faites
personne ne vous en voudra de le faire
il faut faire l'émission de Marine Le
Pen et peut-être que ça décidera la
semaine pour suivante Emmanuel Macron ne
le faire ou d'envoyer des gens mais je
pense que la question de se pose même
pas et je ne comprends pas vous vous
connaissez que vous hésitiez deux
minutes vous qui avez tendance un peu à
passer par des chemins traverses lorsque
l'enjeu est national
c'est que imagine que il fasse
l'émission et que le président ne vienne
pas et puis que Marine soit élu oui ça
va ça ne sera eu des conséquences série
peut pas ça on peut pas on peut pas être
désigné comme étant celui qui a amené
tel qu'on dit Mathieu
c'est c'est comme c'est comme moi je dis
souvent un truc je dis moi je dis
t'invite t'invite de gars à ton
anniversaire bien sûr il y en a un qui
dit je t'invite 10 personnes il y en a
cinq qui disent je viens pas tu vas
quand même faire ton anniversaire bien
sûr les absents ont toujours invité
c'est souvent ce qui m'arrive moi mon
anniversaire j'invite plein de gens il y
en a plein qui viennent pas bien sûr je
le fais quand même bah voilà ce monsieur
refuse de parler aux jeunes alors Gilles
Verdez vous comprenez alors je suis
désespéré de répondre oui parce que
c'était l'émission que j'attendais pour
enfin poser les vraies questions les
questions des vrais gens de vie
quotidienne les questions qui ne sont
pas abordées les questions de pouvoir
d'achat les questions de mal-être les
vrais gens à les poser à Marine Le Pen
et manuel Macron les vrais questions
j'attendais ça mais à partir du moment
où l'un des deux dit non je trouve que
vu tout ce que vous représentez jusque
C8 représente vous ne pouvez pas passer
outre c'est à dire qu'entre guillemets
c'est pour ça que je suis très amer vous
êtes piégé par le refus d'Emmanuel
Macron mais vous êtes tellement
important cette émission elle allait
poser tellement les bases du deuxième
tour que vous ne pouvez pas faire que
Marine Le Pen donc hélas est mortifié je
réponds oui parce que vous ne pouvez pas
faire autrement et j'espère qu'Emmanuel
Macron va changer d'avis parce que ça le
grandirait aussi et vous savez ce que
j'ai dit ce matin aux personnes j'ai dit
j'aurais eu et vous le savez voilà j'ai
jamais caché on affection pour Jean-Luc
Mélenchon aussi voilà qui est venu
souvent dans mes émissions c'est le
premier d'ailleurs premier homme
politique est devenu dans une de mes
émissions Jean-Luc ils sont étaient
Jean-Luc Mélenchon bien entendu je
savais que Jean-Luc Mélenchon Emmanuel
Macron je l'aurais fait pareil c'est pas
parce que c'est Marine Le Pen c'est
voilà je fais je traite les deux
candidats voilà et c'est vrai que ça
aurait été Jean-Luc Mélenchon Marine Le
Pen les deux je vous dis parce qu'on
avait demandé on avait demandé à tout le
monde avant on est obligé même de
demander même les gens qui étaient pas
favoris mais on a demandé et c'est vrai
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon et Marine Le Pen
avaient dit oui tout de suite Jean-Luc
était prêt à le faire sur
l'entre-deux-tours et le président
sortant a dit qu'il allait réfléchir
donc c'est pas complètement mort
peut-être que il va peut-être qu'il va
venir faire un truc avec nous peut-être
faire autre chose ou peut-être voilà on
est en train de voir sentir le besoin
aussi mais peut-être qu'il va se dire je
dois faire cette émission pour me
confronter au vagin tu veux pas rester
impuissant comme ça face à la situation
ils ont c'est la loi c'est comme ça tu
vois bien que c'est une injustice énorme
oui c'est une injustice pour Marine Le
Pen déjà parce que Marine Le Pen elle
accepte de faire l'émission et
aujourd'hui on lui dit tu ne peux pas
faire l'émission parce que ton
adversaire refuse de faire l'émission
c'est injuste et je trouve que c'est une
injustice pour l'émission en elle-même
qui a toujours donné la parole à tout le
monde à tous les politiques voilà vous
l'avez toujours fait et moi parce que
c'est pas le seul candidat il y a
d'autres candidats qui disaient qu'ils
ne voulaient pas aller dans face à Baba
alors qu'il n'était pas invité et c'est
même candidat je les vois sur internet
sur brut sur combiné chez Jordan Deluxe
voilà et qui viennent pas dans
l'émission je trouve ça dégueulasse
c'est une émission de grande écoute
d'utilité publique et c'est vraiment
injuste et je suis d'accord avec Mathieu
vous devriez la faire coûte que coûte
est-ce que l'amende mettrait en péril
économie de la chaîne est-ce que vous
l'avez chiffré donc elle est symbolique
en fait oui mais bon oui mais bon quand
même c'est à dire que il y a des règles
parce que si moi je le fais après
il y a des règles Kelly moi c'était ça
ma question c'est quoi le bénéfice
risque qu'est-ce que vous avez fait vos
calculs si elle le calcule
la menthe c'est pas une grosse à moi en
fait
malgré tout même symbolique après non
alors comme a dit Mathieu si Marine Le
Pen gagne et que si t'es invité je vous
dis si tu dois faire un match de tennis
et que tu dis aux deux mecs de venir sur
le terrain et qu'il y en a un qui dit
bah non je veux pas venir bah l'autre
gagne pas forcé
Emmanuel Macron a décidé c'est son choix
et je le dis en tout affection de ne pas
faire campagne cette année il a fait un
meeting et SIG cinq interview c'est pas
parce qu'il fait pas campagne qui doit
empêcher tous les autres de le faire
encore une fois il y a des règles encore
une fois l'enjeu ça serait 30 70 sur un
pas d'enjeu ça serait du spectacle 49 51
la différence elle va se faire sur des
jeunes elle va se faire justement en
parlant avec des des policiers des gens
handicapés alors il y a ma mère je
m'écris là on dirait elle me dit il faut
la faire absolument 3 points il faut
absolument que Marine Le Pen la face
d'autant que vous dites si elle l'a fait
elle va gagner on dira que Cyril dit si
ça se trouve elle traîne très mauvaise
émission elle va tirer une balle dans le
pied c'est pas parce qu'on vient c'est
pas parce qu'on parle qu'on est bon elle
doit le faire et j'espère vraiment
qu'Emmanuel Macron le fera et ne fuira
pas le débat ou au pire s'il veut pas
qu'il enverra des des Gabriel Attal et
des gens de proches de lui pour pour la
deuxième émission mais je trouve que
nous priver d'un débat aussi important à
49 51 c'est véritablement nous privé
d'une démocratie lui qui hier lors du
discours n'a parlé que de démocratie
alors la démocratie c'est nous laisser
choisir je vais vous dire aussi
également ce matin on m'a dit oui c'est
vrai que c'est compliqué parce que
Marine Le Pen euh tes missions s'appelle
Touche pas à mon poste c'est quand même
en minérale la prémission phare c'est
quand même un clin d'oeil à touche pas
mon pote SOS racine donc c'est vrai
qu'on est on est voilà c'est c'est le
thème de l'émission C'est c'est quand
même tous ensemble le lait de motif de
l'émission c'est tous ensemble c'est
qu'il y a pas de différence etc et il y
a plein de gens qui m'ont dit si tu
invites que Marine Le Pen c'est pas toi
ça n'est pas Cyril Hanouna voilà donc il
j'ai répondu j'ai dit le problème c'est
que c'est Marine Le Pen au deuxième tour
et ça aurait été Jean-Luc Mélenchon ça
aurait été Philippe Poutou ça aurait été
Yannick Jadot je les ai invité aussi
mais c'est vrai que Gilles c'est ce que
tu me semblais dire on peut pas faire un
match tout seul elle ne peut pas faire
le match sans adversaire et moi je pense
à vous et encore une fois c'est trop
important c'est trop important pour
qu'on puisse dire pour qu'on puisse dire
que Marine Le Pen est venu et
qu'Emmanuel Macron lui n'est pas venu ça
crée un déséquilibre moi c'est pas du
tout la monde c'est presque l'éthique
c'est presque la démocratie c'est du
coup du coup mais Emmanuel Macron tend
un piège qui est redoutable et ben ne
tombons pas dedans c'est la première
fois que je vous en moule à qui
qu'est-ce qui vous arrive
j'hésite pas j'hésite pas non réfléchis
pas il y a jamais réfléchi jusqu'à
maintenant tu es allé à l'instant
mais tu peux pas parler comme dans un
jeu si tu triches
c'est quand même bien que ah non pendant
plein d'années pendant le vaccin tu nous
a expliqué qu'il fallait obéir aux
règles qu'il fallait être dans la
démocratie ce qu'il fallait pas insulter
Macron que c'était de la démocratie
qu'il fallait voter là tu vas aller
au-delà de la démocratie rien à voir tu
veux te [ __ ] de la guerre de tout le
monde qu'est-ce qu'il fait il fait il
fait comme il a toujours fait Raymond ça
n'a rien à voir tu sais pourquoi tu sais
pourquoi c'est pas pareil parce que là
Cyril démocratie Cyril là il respecte
les règles il dit voilà je vous invite
tel jour je vous invite tel jour la
première personne dit oui la deuxième
personne dit non bon bah si elle dit non
c'est son choix de pas venir mais on va
pas tout annuler parce qu'elle ne peut
pas venir la règle c'est de donner deux
heures à l'un et de donner deux heures à
l'autre
tu ne peux pas donner deux heures mais
c'est la loi sinon n'importe où on va
faire la petite rencontre que il ne veut
même pas venir et pour le moment si je
suis bien renseigné il veut même pas
envoyer ses billes c'est la politique
qui l'a fait ça veut dire qu'il refuse
de lui mettre à nous horloge il refuse
le débat tu dis pas de campagne tu dis
qu'il ne veut pas de campagne il fait la
campagne puisque depuis hier il est
partout dans le Nord la Strasbourg là il
bombarde je suis désolé je vis pas sur
un marché moi je suis désolé la
télévision je vais regarder pour
l'écouter mais moi je suis comme toi
regarde ma pancarte je suis comme toi
je trouve qu'il a à perdre parce que en
venant il pourrait débattre il pourrait
donner ses idées il pourrait dire ce
qu'il va pas chez Marine Le Pen il a 5
ans de bagages derrière lui de Président
il est armé pour aller face à Marine Le
Pen je pense que quand
même il va d'accord
elle expose son bilan et lui il vient
après dans une autre émission il vient
quand alors
c'est ce que je viens de vous dire
Marine Le Pen va venir devant 10
personnes d'accord mercredi c'était
prévu on pense après c'est Emmanuel
Macron de venir devant 10 personnes en
quoi j'ai rien compris
j'ai totalement compris regardez bien
c'est très marrant c'est peut-être con
ce que je vais dire regardez tous ceux
qu'on voulait interdire c'est moi tous
ceux ont dit faut pas que des hémories
parlent faut pas que je vais mourir par
faut le musée quand il parlait pas il
est à 18 16 14 il s'est mis à parler il
s'est mis à faire des métiers on l'a vu
il a commencé par la raison il a
commencé à chuter et les Français sont
pas cons les Français quand ils ont été
dans les urnes ils ont dit je vais pas
voter pour la marionnette de Zemmour et
fou moi ça en l'air et son programme de
merde il a fait s'il a fait le score
qu'il a fait parce qu'on l'a laissé
parler et moi je pense que nous on va
débattre